my thing was just not having protection
yeah that's my
biggest wound that comes out
in all my relationships jada pinkett
smith has found the common thread in her
relationships if we don't talk about it
we're not going to get to the other side
in a preview for wednesday's episode of
red table talk jada and her co-host
daughter willow smith and mother adrian
gammy banfield norris sit down with
mother hunger author kelly mcdaniel for
a conversation on mother-daughter
dynamics that's where jada reveals the
biggest wound that comes out most in her
personal relationships lack of
protection i've looked for
craziest kinds of protection protection
and i don't have a really good sense of
like what's safe and what's not the
reason her mom believes it all started
when her mother jada's grandmother died
the environment it was
my addiction
she found her security through my mother
yeah right and yeah but when mommy died
that's when my addiction really took off
she died when i was in middle school
yeah 11 12 years old that's a really
important time to feel secure and safe
that's when your womanhood starts yeah
yeah yeah and that's when she lost her
security yeah you know my mother was her
backbone and that moment impacted jada's
sense of security going forward and her
house was safe right
and so once
she was gone
there was no safety so then i went into
the world and created my own safety and
that was crazy opening up about personal
truths on red table talk should come as
no surprise back in 2018 when the show
first started jada told et she wants
viewers to walk away from the show
feeling a sense of relief oh and i'm
hoping that it will give people the
freedom also in their lives to find
their truth and to have more courage to
live their truth because really that's
what this table is about you know it's
us
finding our truth sometimes discovering
our truth and having the courage to live
that truth you know and so that's all
this this table is about sharing and
discovery and i definitely think that
especially women right now we need a
place where we can talk about real
things in a real way because
um
it's complicated times and we're trying
to figure out we have more freedom now
than ever
you know we're all just trying to figure
out what does it mean to be a woman what
does it mean to be
a wife a mother
a superstar
[Music]
you